I think nine modules are
once-in-a-generation politician love him
or hate him a lot of people do hate him
but I you know a lot of people love him
as well he's brought down David Cameron
he split the Labour Party's destroyed
the Liberal Democrats you're not really
gonna replace him very easily are you
but I think Diane's a different kind of
politician and she's probably a little
bit more steel even Nigel so you're
about interest so it'll be less less
internal issues in UK probably it's
interesting that you mentioned the
internal issues because there has been
some infighting in the party Alexandre
Philips the former head of media
defecting to the Conservatives saying
that there was a aggressive and
testosterone-fueled
atmosphere do you think that's a problem
in you Kip well she might be right
there's certainly a lot of testosterone
floating around but and if that's a bad
thing wouldn't you know it's a party
that isn't necessarily professional
politicians I don't we aspire to that
you kid was about change you know it's
it's affected huge change in the UK
almost without it election any one to
Westminster if you look at trees of may
now she's adopting a you keep agenda and
I think our job is to keep her feet to
the fire and make it happen in terms of
pressure you've had your own issues with
some people within the party most
notably douglas Carswell
Nigel Faraj has said that he doesn't
know why he joined the party do you
think that he should remain as you kept
MP I think Douglas joined the party
because of the most Euroskeptic seats in
the entire country and if he hadn't have
joined he would have lost at the
election well had a damn good chance so
I think you know I I think it was good
that he came at the time it gave us
momentum but I think his values and like
you kept values and how as you kept
going to try and I think in terms of
dying James I think she's gonna be a
breath of fresh air
you know so I think she said in a speech
one ground a school girl to another it's
gonna be quite interesting she's
certainly going to have to try and bring
the factions together in you cope isn't
she well this is very much a media
invention I know you love to talk about
splits in UK it's not really a media
it pulls the hell of a trouble with
respect it's not really a medium my
invention to split it is a media thing
you've got Douglas castle and Hamilton
and a few hangers on as we saw in the
hall today 99.9 percent of the
membership are behind Nigel and the same
with diane james douglas Carswell is
your only MP though it's interesting you
call him a hanger on all that is
regrettable I agree are you going to
continue to give money to the party
under Diane James's leadership I can't
uh under Diane James I think we'll do
fantastically you know Nigel of and I
talked about the future we're actually
quite keen on maybe taking the message
out into continental Europe we had a
fantastic time with the Trump rally in
America and some of the issues resonate
there and I think part of our mission is
to take it into Europe I'm asking to
give an eye on every possible how I'm
asking because I know that you've said
that you're quite keen to set up and
fund another separate campaign group and
anti-eu campaign group so will that is
that still your plan are you still
planning to do that well we already have
a campaign group it's called leaved on a
year nearly a million online people
follow it and it reaches out to over 10
million people every week you know
during the campaign our best-performing
video is the 8 million people watch
there so we've got tremendous reach
already and we'll continue to campaign
on the issues that we that we all agree
on so where are you going to be focusing
your fundraising so where are you going
to be fixing your funding you're going
to be focusing it on you Kip or on the
leaf new year group I think we're today
very relieved I and J James 1 I think
most of the major donors that you kept
going to stick with it they're going to
get behind her and I think we're gonna
see and reinvigorated UK if anything if
I had a 40-ounce Nigel that he was a bit
soft really on some of the people that
dissented and really the organisation
could have been more professionally run
I think Diane is quite steely she comes
from a business background
Nigel was an inspirational politician
his man management may not always be the
best eye
okay and banks thank you for your
thoughts on the new need review clip
Sophie thank you very much I really
enjoyed it thanks